you're more advanced you're gonna just
start releasing all to mention idea
bodies get selected orient your body so
the force is going down to the back
Whitman foot and then if you can you're
going to start relaxing
let's work with arms right there
it's time I would take this sons front
arm down you'll get the tricep and you
are
[Music]
so past our tricep to your other
this way so we got past
you use your here I have my ground pot
and then I'm going to have a new brown
bat of this foot oh oh nothing
this foot is now projecting the energy
so there's a yield than this but I'll
move since energy okay yield change feet
back foot has the ground field then the
front foot is gonna have I'm not just
yield boom deal now the front foot
projections around
so give it more energy if you want to
stop them from run use them all you can
stop them all right give some edge let's
go when he'll wait I he'll wait you lose
power
Midway
- hi unique is wrong
so let's change our staff yokas buddy
yeah we just want this this weight
shifting exercise that's all we're doing
it's just a weight shifting that
wait wait it's not a technique to
shift weight behind the new ground path
I'm on the back foot and I'm moving it
to the front foot go better come on
we're not throwing anyone so let's go
give it some energy work on this
[Music]
and I'm going back to it now so the back
arm is keep the back plate but I'm
stepping backwards
[Music]
feel the earth pushing back on you with
your right leg that's it push with your
left leg keep it on the ground
don't push it off the earth push
we're gonna step backwards this time the
front foot is going to become the let's
say remember the whole video yes why
those women are trying to win okay so
you got to put some effort in your
training
so I have the front pass I'm going to
come up front pass
whoa come up and use the back pass
oh come on back
come on you know what do it slow like
that when you go slow you're going to
have to get to the other side of his
body
otherwise you follow other side
[Music]
all this change
all with the inside foot now it marks
the inside
[Music]
the hand that does the arm dried does
the head
it is that our buddy shall and on you
the hand that does the arm well we're
doing a different kind of technique not
what you think
so I start here but as I go around my
arm is sorry that's our spiral that's
spiraling down I don't want to turn him
[Music]
make your move start making a smaller
sub train sub clean